how much was the motion being in a year
if you don't mind sharing like off music
i don't know off music i know that i had
like touring music i know i had like you
know almost a half a meal in my bank
account wow you know so it's like when
you have that
and you um
man a half it goes so fast and you went
through that [ __ ] i went through it
helping people i went through it doing a
lot for myself it wasn't like i went
through it like buying cars and houses
i went through it over time
and uh and when i say half a mil it
wasn't up that high but you know we're
around that era i mean that area but i
mean you know you can [ __ ] off your
money man try to be [ __ ] save the
world dude you can't what were the
things you learned like uh that you're
gonna try to because like i feel like
right now you're in a position to
probably make more money than you ever
have exactly exactly what are the things
that you learned that you're gonna like
try to do differently now that you're
well one don't um don't uh spend all
your time
you know spend any of your financial
investments that you've made well
actually one i'll tell i'll say this
because uh gucci said it the best and
i'm like not like a gucci [ __ ]
enthusiast or nothing like that i'm not
hating i'm just saying i heard this and
i thought it was very intelligent
if i didn't
if i didn't
the last five six years act like this
was a [ __ ] party
you know what i'm saying and really
approached it like this is business
i would have a lot of money right now
but instead i was trying to do like
trying to be
and i wasn't even buying them crazy buy
some sunglasses by like eight pairs of
jays get your homie like here's 20 grand
here's 30 grand you was passing out 20
grand to the homies
[ __ ] yeah oh yeah you're you're nice
yeah
so and but that's not
so i got to a point where i felt like i
was like
like i hope they don't hear this and
think that i'm like
you know it's my fault i did it you know
what i'm saying but yeah that's how man
you can't be man you got to take the
[ __ ] serious there's a window you get
your [ __ ] money you save it up you
know what i'm saying don't give it away
to your friends bro well you don't do
anything with it man grow the [ __ ] up
stop partying
like yo you're making some money you
have a big career like dude it's time
it's time to look in the mirror and go
oh [ __ ] that party [ __ ] is old you know
what i'm saying it's hard as an artist
though we use it as an excuse like i'm
some creative [ __ ] drug guy
drinking yeah whatever
um but yeah but to everybody out there
man take that [ __ ] money man
save it give it to your family give it
to your mom and dad to hold give it to
i don't know figure it out dude because
you only got so much time and you can
make a lot of money doing this [ __ ]